you told me by age 26 you had 11
different businesses you said around
that in your early or mid-20s you were
producing Broadway shows that you were
like in the mix at a very early early
age how did that kind of come to be and
what were those 11 businesses
[Music]
all right man we're live we uh
we we always just kind of hop into
things but uh on the Pod today we have
Michael Harris but do you like to go by
Harry O or Michael what do you like to
go by well people call me you know
people that know me by Harry oh call me
Harry call me oh or Michael whatever
works so I'll kind of set this up but
basically I'll tell you I I I've I've
read a lot about you and I've read about
a lot of the work that you've done the
way that we got connected was
we have a mutual friend named Chris who
um has this has this thing called The
Last Mile which helps people when they
get out of prison helps them get jobs at
tech companies and he's been bragging
about you because I told him you you
can't see it now because I redecorated
but on my wall I used to have a picture
of Tupac and Dre and Easy E because I
loved NWA and I loved like the
rebellious culture of of people who
created cool stuff and he goes hey you
know I know the guy who is part you know
part brains behind all that and I go
what and he said who you you know he
said your name I go oh I've read all
about him and he goes well I I he's my
he's my buddy so that's kind of that's
kind of how we got connected and so I
thought today we can kind of talk a
little bit about your story
so people can learn about you but then
also we can talk a little bit about
business and kind of the stuff that you
went through so you uh where are you
from
uh Los Angeles I'm from the east side of
Los Angeles California you told me by
age 26 you had 11 different businesses
you said around the in your early or
mid-20s you were producing Broadway
shows that you were like in the mix at a
very early early age how did that kind
of come to be and what were those 11
businesses
well I used to be I used to uh I used to
own a limousine first business I had was
a limousine service uh
that was uh quite profitable and I also
had a construction company I had
production companies I had music
companies I had a
salons like beauty salons I had a
real estate investment companies so I
was just kind of like all over the place
and I also produced uh
not just concerts and plays but also uh
I supported clubs in the city
how big was the the limo business
I had I had a I had about
30 30 cars and so but there was a luxury
uh limousines they were Ultra scratches
at the time it was pretty uh pretty
impressive it's the style car that we
had yeah what type of monthly Revenue
can a limo business make
you know it depends I stay pretty book I
spent a lot of time
um advertising so a lot of times uh
I would have beyond the cards that I
possess I would have uh people calling
me and saw a lot of the services that uh
surrounded me
didn't have business and so I would form
them I would form out the rest of the
business that I didn't have the capacity
to serve so a lot of times I would
provide opportunities for the other uh
car services that didn't advertise as
much as I did so maybe somebody needed
100 cars and only had 30 I could provide
them with a hundred because I would
parlay that out to uh what they call
form out to the other companies which
you get 50 percent of the uh service
that is conducted
right right would you actually get half
you get half of what it is because
you're the one who initiated the sale
what how old were you and how old were
you when you had a limo company that had
30 30 cars
probably maybe 23 years old how on Earth
does that happen what age should you
start working
well you know as a youngster I started
working I used to work at it I mean I
likely places uh to learn uh business
structure uh when I was a kid I mean
like I'm talking about like
before I even went to Junior High School
I worked at a shoe shine parlor and and
at that shoe shine parlor uh it was in
my neighborhood but it was two shoe
shine Impalas and there's one on one end
of the corner and one was on the other
end of the corner
what I was able to learn from that
experience as a 12 13 year old kid uh 11
12 13 year old kid is competition and
how business was ran and these two guys
competed with each other but they also
hired you know kids from the
neighborhood to work at these shoeshine
parlors and we competed with each other
and so I learned a lot about business
from that practice in that process but I
also learned I used to listen a lot you
know a lot of people come in different
from different walks of life it could be
preachers and business owners uh people
from the street and you would just you
know while you're shining their shoes
and listening at a young age and you're
hearing different uh hearing about
different opportunities and how people
approach business differently and so I
was always like a sponge at a young age
but you know friends and I also learned
I never judge a book by its cover like
sometimes the guy might pull up and be
in a nice car and you're like people was
you know trying to get that customer and
this guy comes in may may only have one
or two pair of shoes and may not even be
a Tipper but then a guy pulls up in a
station wagon or a regular car and he
might have 30 cars in the you know 30
shoes in there and also it's a big
temper so it just just learning how to
read people and you know just that whole
competitive thing that was amongst us as
you used to compete in you know be at
our best be dressed you know represent
and you know holding in on our skill so
I try to learn something from everything
I always did as a kid like how do I use
this moving forward you know what is it
what's the lesson you know learned here
you know so uh that was that was and my
mother also on a a restaurant in the
neighborhood and I watched how she
navigated that and how she would how she
handled her customers and how she worked
with her staff and you know actually
remember before she bought that business
when she used to work for the people
that she bought it from how she you know
raised up Rose up in that in terms of
manage meant and then acquired that
business and so just watching
people uh be effective in business at a
young age had a profound effect on me
and you end up kind of getting in
trouble which I'll let you tell a story
in your 20s but before that how how big
was your Empire in terms of employees at
its peak I probably had about a hundred
and
150 employees
and can you reveal like how much revenue
like this whole the whole empire was
bringing in
that was me I was making millions and I
was I mean you know it's 35 36 years ago
so I don't remember exact I mean that
builds up though what do you what did
you do with your money
I always invested in real estate in real
estate so you're not not public equities
you liked real estate and you're so
you're buying real estate what your
neighborhood yeah yeah all over in any
way I could find a deal uh you know to
buy up you know like rehab properties as
well as the luxury of properties and
um business uh Outlets I would I would
purchase it
how many did you own how many how many
buildings
probably 30 or 40 buildings damn you
still own them
it's been a long time brother
I mean that adds up that adds up I I
just started purchasing some stuff
um about three years ago and I'm like if
I just get one or two every single year
I mean these definitely add up and you
you bought it a good time I bet
oh yeah it was uh it was a you know I
was in a position about about uh by a
different type of properties that came
into my preview so but the thing that
you're most famous for is the
entertainment stuff when did you what
led you to entertainment was it the
plays at first no one one of my first
well I said limousine was one of my
first major business but I added up in a
um and open up a uh
it went in that building I was telling
you about that was on 54th and Crenshaw
I opened up a studio and we created a
company it was I believe it was called
the jingle Factory and what I would do
is make commercials for local uh
businesses and so with the local radio
stations and so uh like klj kjlhm K Ace
and and so that that brought me around
musicians so you know I would have
people sing Hooks and make certain
melodies for it to go with you know
certain businesses to give it a certain
aesthetic and so a lot of uh
producers and singers would come into
the studio and
I kind of just kind of drifted off into
that world
uh so I've managing groups and
uh working with uh different record
labels and production companies and at
the same time as my limousine girl was
growing I worked with a lot of
production companies as well and artists
would use my services so just being in
that Circle connected me to uh that
world
and so for different reasons I got
involved and uh
the music business was there anyone that
is or that I would know of that you
started working with like really early
around on around that time at the was it
called the jingle Factory
yeah the jingle Factory was makes
commercial it was commercial based like
that you know we did commercials in the
city so basically that I did did my own
Jingles for my own uh Limousine Service
as well so no that was a non-celebrity
that was just commercial but at the same
time I started working with uh you know
Motown I started working with at the
time old town was uh
uh pretty hot in the city so I was
working with Motown behind the scenes a
lot and then how did that kind of go
into the production companies
well I created a production called why
not production
and I just felt like during that time
um it was hard for people to look like
me to uh
to really uh
get a stronghold in the city so I
decided to create my own production
company so and I would you know be
available to help produce artists that
didn't have the financial other thought
to be able to do it themselves and and
somebody brought me a play opportunity
and I
I never I never was involved in plays
into that moment and I just thought it
was just a real creative space for
people who were you know in the movie
business but didn't have work at the
time but could horn in on a craft and
also provide entertainment in the
community and a lot of people may not
have been used to uh experiencing the
plays and so that gave me an opportunity
to bring that kind of entertainment uh
to my community so it was very exciting
I got to meet some some pretty Heavy
Hitters
doing an opportunity I've met a Paul
Winfield I met Vanessa Williams I'm at
uh Richard Lawson I met uh Ruby d uh
I mean
Al Freeman I mean I could just go down
the list uh there's a number of people
who uh work with me on this uh
production I work with a guy named Woody
King he's out of New York who's the
director and Ron Milner was happened to
be the uh the author of this particular
play called Checkmate and I was able to
take it to various cities and uh
ultimately
got it to Broadway with Anita Landers
I'm 46 and Broadway in
my life Came Crashing Down right before
we actually launched on Broadway we was
on Broadway but I didn't get to Market
and promoted the way I normally do
I like the market and promote the
projects that I'm involved with
and so what does that mean you you
basically that you know someone came to
you and they go hey man I got this idea
for this play I got here's my vision
yada yada here's what I think could be
the outcome and you're like all right
cool I'll put up 100K I'm half owner and
I'll help make connections you're going
to do a lot of the day-to-day work I'll
oversee and I'll make some connections
and or were you more Hands-On like
what's that look like
okay like when you talk about like what
I was telling you about all my
investments was consistent like I would
like to come into the management aspect
of it what that does though uh helps me
understand the business okay I may have
management skills but I may not have a a
an Insight on that particular business
so part of that that that that
relationship that merging of that
relationship you need to teach me
everything you know about what you do
and then I you know compile that with my
management skills and then we could you
know move on to the next level but that
was part of what I would do you know I
would come in and decide if this is
something I want to invest in and I
would become the managing partner but
also I want to learn everything that
everybody here knows so that I could be
effective in that position and so that's
that's usually I always took
what's it like working with and by the
way at this point you're still in your
20s yes and you were working with some
up-and-coming people but you're
definitely probably working with some
established people what did they think
about this guy they say this I mean you
got this tough guy persona now I bet you
had that same Persona back then you know
you could be in you you can be
intimidating I imagine they're like
well
I I I'm saying that's my opinion and if
I had to do business with you I'd be
like man I don't want to make this guy
mad and so if you're in your 20s and
like oh this young black guy from uh
he's talking about living in L.A now
he's wanting to be out here in New York
putting on these plays like who who's
this guy think he is like where where
did you deal with
but I always respect other people's
territory you know no matter what
business you're in and when I always
deal with people respectfully you know I
mean that maybe it's the Persona the
perception of me and then it's the
reality of me and so the reality is that
I always was straight up you know so if
there may be that tension there may be
that consideration before they get to
know me but then once they get to know
it oh this guy's you know he's up you
know straight up 100 you know keep it
real you know
it wasn't you know I did stake that up I
don't know
probably later on when the death row
stuff happened I just think people
conflate everybody's attitude as one and
you know we all were different you know
we all came from different uh Vantage
points uh to help create that and I just
think that sometimes people don't pull
back and say you know
who are the individuals that was a part
of that uh
unity and uh
that's a that's a different
that that will bring about a different
perception once people got to know who
you are you know I come from a pretty
tough neighborhood I I don't I won't
argue that and I think that you have to
be pretty strong to survive it uh and
especially with certain
businesses that I was in as a youth you
had to be pretty strong to survive it
and a lot of things I did at my younger
youth I'm not really proud of especially
now today after being away for 33 years
and
and you know going through that
experience and reflecting your back on
on my quick rise as heavy fall you know
but at the same time I always try to
stay positive and
and try to see what that Journey had to
offer so what you said um the plays um
the play didn't work out because your
life Came Crashing Down what's that mean
right when we went through the
pre-broadway and got ready you know open
full full scale
I was arrested and uh sent to prison uh
what were the charges
I was uh I was arrested for one for
attempted murder and
to uh later for drug uh conspiracy and
the the later the uh drug the attempted
murder was I was exonerated at the end
after 30 after this goddamn 23 years but
you know I knew I was innocent and I
think that's made me take it you know
lightly and I didn't really I kept
working when I was out on build not
thinking that this would
uh
the results that happened would happen I
thought I was uh you know I would be
Vindicated and
life was upside down
what were you guilty of the drug charges
yeah I used to be involved in drugs I
and um so I was also uh
even though I had got out of the drug
business you know you get pulled back in
based on some previous uh phone calls I
had got out but still you know that's
they call that Karma you know
you have to pay the piper
and when I when you Google your name one
of the first thing comes up it's this
interview did you did I forget the
publication but the article said at one
point you're doing something I think it
said close to a million dollars a day in
drug sales
is that true they said too was it two
million a day yeah I think I said too
I'm not proud of that so what what's the
story of that it was hard work I mean
you know I mean the thing is uh even
that's Coke I guess yes it was cocaine
yeah and I think that uh like I was
saying before uh
whatever I put myself to uh in a better
difference it was it was like
I put myself to it you know and then it
was like only after watching the uh
repercussions throughout my community
and communities across the country that
I realized that
yo what was making me uh Rich was also
making me poor in spirit and in a
culture you know I was helping to
destroy my own community and so
you know so I don't really take a lot of
joy and talking about
the amount of money I made in that
business even though I was engaged and I
was
I was pretty uh focused in that business
when I was young and misguided in that
business venture
but uh I had a lot of time to reflect
and I bet that's confusing because
whenever you know I start something and
it starts working on working out I get
it's like a dopamine rush you know just
seeing the sales come in I mean it's
exciting you know like it's fun
um in your case it's even though people
were getting hurt it's definitely
exhilarating and it is exciting and even
if you're using the money to invest in
cool stuff that helps your community
it's still
and it hurts people it's still exciting
I mean I bet that's still an
exhilarating adventurous life and you
gotta understand so at a young age
you know just yeah you gotta see it's
got to put everything in his proper
context you know like I'm growing up
people selling weed you know there's no
there's no harm you know it's like and
then this thing is introduced to the
community and and it's just the next
level from selling marijuana or whatever
it is and you they say you know you're
involved and all you see is the dollars
you know what you're making the
transactions you know really because
everybody was you know you smoke weed
next day you get up you go to work you
do what you do you don't really know you
had no previous uh
Insight on what this could could become
and so it's just like okay this person
is buying you selling it it's in your
community it's available that's it
that's all you see and then when you see
later on when you see that this is not
like marijuana this is something else it
is changing the the uh
it's just changing the whole
makeup of the community you know people
are just not themselves no more and now
it's like whoa you know especially if
you're a conscious person and you was
raised and a good you know family
setting and now you're out here hustling
and you're hustling in a way that
other people that have become vulnerable
to this particular drug which I never
use so I didn't know I didn't know what
it felt like but that you know it's
people that I cared about later I would
see them fall victim to it and you know
that's that Karma I'm talking about it
comes back to you you know it's like wow
this is what I'm doing
so yeah I made a lot of money it was
exciting it was adventurous it was it
was uh enterprising but then it also had
that side that you
you can't ignore
and then you got what was your sentence
for 33 years and that was mostly the
attempted murder or the yeah that's
that's that was not my sentence I had a
25 of life and on top of that I had a 20
years since for the federal us with the
feds
damn what's that feel like hearing that
it's unbelievable but but it's real I
mean like the the uh
the criminal system is real I mean it's
it's like a lot of people I think
conversations like the one we have and
should be had more I think people just
see the glitz and glamor of a particular
lifestyle and and the fact that a lot of
us have very little patience because
some of us live in conditions that are
unbearable so you just want to get out
however you got to get out and so
you don't realize that the patience that
that you need that you can exercise that
you should exercise could save you a
lifetime a misery and so it's you know
in hindsight you can see you know I
can't reverse
you know so I I believe I should be a
conduit for that I believe I should be
able to talk to people that are poised
to make some of the same uh useful
mistakes that I made thinking that it's
gonna solve the problem when it creates
multiple problems uh and it affects your
family any community in ways that you
can't even imagine
when you were so you started death row
or and I want to hear about that while
in prison after you went in
yes
how on Earth does that work
well you know I'm
enterprising
what do you want me to tell you I mean
what do you want me to say what's it I
mean when you're just sit there you have
a visitor or you write letters you're
doing phone calls and and someone comes
to you and be like hey man you want to
start a record label I mean I don't even
know I mean how long were you in in
there before you you kind of got this
idea or or how'd that happen
when I got told you I was involved in
different aspects of the entertainment
business already so it's kind of like I
was already bitten by the bug uh what
happened was uh
uh I don't know if I should tell you
this part of maybe you should wait till
the movie come out but uh maybe you know
maybe maybe even already heard some
aspects of this but it's just uh you
know I was uh
I I just still had all this energy
inside of me that I wanted to do
something I didn't want I didn't want my
sentence uh to be the end of me and you
know I just I just couldn't stop you
know I'm a kind of guy that only slept
three hours a day and uh
and like I said we're in 11 businesses
how do you go to prison to sit there and
then be okay with that you know it's
just not what it is so you always you're
trying to find something outside of your
environment that allows you to stay
alive
uh in spite of your circumstances and in
spite of your sentence that has been
imposed you just you know you're still
youthful and you still you still want to
have an impact because like I said when
you deal with the totality of a person
and you see that day was more good than
bad than that person
that's
that's what you're trying to get back to
you know what I'm saying like you know
like sometimes I could say just trying
to find a cool place in hell you know
for all the bad things that I did you
know praying that God could you know
forgive me for that at the same time
being able to give some back to my
community that they can use
instead of something they shouldn't use
so what's that creation Story look like
um who uh who contacted I mean I I don't
I I told you I read uh
ruthless is it is that what the book's
called ruthless is that by Jerry Heller
so yeah yeah so Rufus was before death
row right right right right right so
death row is the if you say if you will
the next iteration of Ruthless uh
because one of the main components of
Rufus was Dr Dre and Dr Dre uh was the
producer
of the music that the that mostly was
produced by NWA mostly all the music
that was released in the NWA was
produced by Dr Dre and so NWA was a
group in Dr Dre was a part of that but
he also was the engine that made it run
but I don't think that Eazy-E rest in
peace and Jerry Heller also deceased
understood
what understood Dre's value it to the
point where it shouldn't have been uh
overlooked and so that opened up an
opportunity
for him to be disgruntled and uh for
sure at night
uh who uh
who actually began to manage Dr Dre
after managing an artist by the name of
DLC
uh who introduced should to Dr Dre and
uh then I was introduced to should
shortly after
and uh that's how that relationship came
he was managing Dr Dre and Doc and uh
we created a company first we created a
Godfather entertainment and then out of
that first death row and so
then who came up with that name
I came up with Godfather entertainment
and and based on my situation you know I
was actually housed on death row in San
Quentin yes and Quinn for I wasn't
sentenced to death row I was housed
there for a short period of time and I
was able to witness young people younger
than myself at the time being sentenced
to death row and I just you know I was
profoundly affected by that and I
thought that uh
go so you hear different versions of the
name because there used to be deaf deaf
like def bro and then we decided to call
it death row which I that's the company
I set up afro records
and you had um you guys yeah I worked
with uh my attorney at the time that was
working with me on my appeal David
Kenner was also part of that partnership
that helped assemble that company for me
while I was behind bars
and you guys I mean you didn't
necessarily you didn't even shape the
genre you created it a little bit you
know you had uh POC Snoop who else was
on there
I mean it's it's the people don't
realize death row didn't have a large
where Oscars just had an effective one
uh and also my ex-wife Lydia she was
also a part of the management team that
helped facilitate the company in the
beginning uh so to answer your question
it's like
the moment the world heard Snoop Dogg
and Dr Dre's voice together
it was it was a game changer you know it
was a
you know a warranty uh was a part of a
group with Snoop two on three again
his relationship with Dr Dre facilitated
Snoop Dogg coming into the fold and uh
DLC working with uh Snoop man
helping him you know up his game in the
rap game and Dr Dre looking to create
another star
and that relationship
forged together just it's just made
magic but there was other members other
producers and other artists that was on
the label female like rage and Jewel the
dog pound
there was a
there was just a lot of synergy there
you know and they all come from
different walks of life and
and it just was that time you know some
things was just time you know the energy
pot came later but uh he uh brought some
of that fire with him too and it's just
put death row in history books like no
other label because a lot of people
don't really understand that death row
was the
the little choo-choo train at wood you
know it just it connected us to so many
different companies that a lot of people
don't even realize that like I mean from
Universal to increasing their
distribution because of the relationship
with their fro and endoscope and Warner
Brothers almost getting out of the music
business because uh the way they
mishandled their relationship with death
row and Interscope I'm just saying it's
it's so many different
aspects to death Row's existence that
most people don't even Ponder they're
too busy with the negative side of in
the drama that some of the people that
was involved participated in but they
don't think about the enterprising
nature of that organization which is
what my focus is is like what it what
was his original intent and what did it
do
in the in the business world that most
people don't talk about isn't the
narrative has been focused now it's been
been moved to a narrow focus and
hopefully I'll be able to expand that up
no
no yeah Snoop Dogg working together it's
Snoop Dogg we acquired uh
death Rowan with partners and I'm the
CEO of the new death row that I helped
create 30 some years ago so it's
exciting let's see how that turned out
what's crazy is
you've been around all these people and
you actually saw them when they were
young you talked about all these
interesting people Denzel Dre Snoop what
uh
what are some of these young guys have
in common you think that kind of because
they're not just like successful
business people they're culture changing
people they changed America they changed
the world what what what attributes did
they have in common
you know what I'm saying well it's just
back up like like seeing Denzel as the
young Denzel and seeing him now he still
is consistent in his character you know
it's certain roles he won't play it's
it's it is the way that he approaches
the craft that attracted me to that
project
Checkmate in the first place he was it
was just always a consummate uh
professional you know it's just he
didn't really hang out you know he just
did what he did and he took off but I
just watched him and I watched his work
ethic and in his projection in the films
that he do uh for people that look like
myself
we're proud you know he makes you proud
he makes you proud and that's not enough
of that in our culture to have people
who can represent you know just in this
craft you know just a strong Focus uh
intriguing individual you know instead
of like you use the word intimidating
like towards me earlier you know it's
like
sometimes that could be off-putting for
people uh and it and it kills
opportunity because people see the book
remember earlier I talked about judging
a book by its cover and uh not really
taking the time you know to connect to
that individual but Denzel has been
really great with that with the Roses
played so it's my honor and pleasure
that they hadn't known him then and to
know him now that he's uh he's a
consummate professional even today he uh
he's always you know thinking about his
thoughts when he when he when he does a
a particular project and NWA and death
row is different now
it it had this uh and by the way when I
said intimidating in part I meant I'm
par I'm intimidated because you've got
this cool demeanor I asked you earlier I
said if you ever say something that you
don't want on the Pod just let me know
and you said
I don't say things I don't mean to say
like you just you got this Clint
Eastwood just like I'm like I just
you've got this coolness about you that
is uh is intimidating as what I meant
and I'm intimidated by your success but
I appreciate the clarification yeah
because you know I'm glad you said that
no and I appreciate that aspect of it
yeah I uh no I just you know I just
think about my thoughts and so that's
why I don't worry I I appreciate you
you're saying that to me uh early on but
I'm usually conscious and if I say it I
meant to say it you know that's what I
mean you're very intentional and I and
that can be intimidating to people
because when I get nervous when they're
if there's silence or I'm nervous I'll
say [__] that I don't even mean to say
you know what I mean yeah you don't seem
to have that attribute I haven't been in
some pretty sticky situations and you
guys say what you mean mean what you say
it could turn out real ugly you know if
you you know if you uh don't understand
your surroundings
you know you got to speak to your
audience you know whatever the artist
may be in in real life I mean in life
you know every day or just in this type
of setting you know like you never know
who could uh benefit from our
conversation today uh or hesitate on
something they're about to do and say
hey you know what that's some wisdom now
let me let me connect to that uh here's
a person that have been through it and
experienced it on different levels and
uh he might have something to say you
know so
thinking about
I'm thinking about setting up me a
podcast you know so you talk about your
success I'm trying I'm gonna be in your
rear view mirror for a second then I'll
be I have a feeling you're gonna only be
in the rearview mirror for a second but
what were you saying about and I think
you said NWA forget who you said you're
right okay they were different in a way
that they provided an opportunity uh
for us to speak now some people don't
like what we said but it was different
you know it was like you had a certain
box that you know black Americans and
and not just black American Hispanics
you know different nationalities that
are sometimes
regulated to a you know a box and so you
don't really get to hear them but
through this mechanism called music
called hip-hop call rap called uh some
people call it gangster rap you know I
just call it reality rap you know
whatever that reality was in US
Community being able to speak to it you
know what I'm saying like becoming your
own CNN or a Fox News you know you can
say this is what's happening good bad or
indifference but this is what's
happening in our community and they were
able to communicate that and so my
intentions was to elevate but at the
same time this thing takes on a life of
his own and so and then you get involved
uh in uh
then it becomes a business and then you
have Executives and producers who start
to see your world even different from
how you see it so later it was altered
but in the in the beginning it was fresh
and raw and uncut you know so you people
are getting mirroring into a community
they know a little about and so that in
that aspect
the the rappers the the music business
was able to
oh [__] shed a light on those
communities in a way that hasn't been
shedded and especially when it came to
police brutality uh you know a lot of
the uh Injustice that was taking place
in those communities it just it just
became a profitable vehicle
that allowed us to talk about things in
cold or in you know through lyrics that
normally you wouldn't even have access
at all doing so
what's the first song that you heard
that you thought oh death row this I'm
onto something
[Music]
well it's it's like I got to hear a lot
of it before it came out so it wasn't I
mean I got to hear
the whole album The Chronic before it
came out and so but the first when I
heard the first song that was done on
Deep Cover soundtrack The Single that
Snoop and Dre did uh and I was in prison
and a lot of guys ah
they weren't really paying attention to
them really until that happened yeah
because it was NWA and other groups that
was out at the time and so uh
uh MCA all these guys that were out you
know and then we had other local uh
artists you know tiny T and Miss Max of
spade and Ice-T and all these different
guys with you know during their solo
career as well but once they heard that
song on the radio uh 187 on the other
cover cop and they heard that melodic
sound come from Snoop in those
uh pop pumping Beats from Dre
it was game over it was Game Over You
know and that was like wow you know
because uh you know I had tried to let
them listen to it before that and they
didn't hear it then once this and I got
a line around the corner they went ahead
and tape now and then it's been like
that ever since you know and I watched
uh I was able to you know watch Trey and
Snoop and then perform at the Super Bowl
and uh I was able to attend the
practices and it was just watching them
at work and flashing back to
what happened so many years ago and just
to see them become
top-notch in their game because we took
it from an independent
type of setting with Rufus in the NWA
and defro was able to submerge itself
into the majors and and become a major
player which changed the game for a lot
of rappers that are quite successful
today
so they were was it was it mostly on
tapes or CD it was tapes still when it
when it first started yes they went to
CDs yeah how much was the cassette back
then so The Chronic came out in 92. what
what year did you go away
I went away at 88. okay so you're in
there for four years
um by the time the chronic comes out how
much is a cassette back then you think
CDs in the late 90s were like 18 what's
it yeah 18 to 23 yeah so that so
so you talking about
nine dollars for a cassette something
like so listen to this I didn't I didn't
realize how fast this happened so I just
I'm looking at the Disco I'm looking at
um
um death Rose uh work so the first album
was The Chronic right that sold like
three million
pretty quickly then it was doggy style
with with Snoop that sold close to seven
million like pretty fast yes then it's
all eyes on me by Park Tupac and then
another Tupac one I mean I didn't
realize
I didn't realize how fast you came out
the gate yeah it changed the game it was
just all of a sudden uh it made people
go crazy too so you know like money just
make you a bigger wherever you are so
you know it's like a lot of a lot of
things changed you know so you're you're
on on a ten dollar cassette tape how
much does death row get like 30 or 40
percent three or four dollars on ten
dollars yeah that's about that's about
right man
it's not bad damn man so I mean what's
it feel like to be in prison and seeing
all that money coming in you're not able
to enjoy it yeah it's been better if I
was on the streets I'd tell you that but
at the same time uh it was good to see
uh
legal activity taking place to make that
kind of money
uh I come from a world where some people
not that you had to but we felt that we
had to do what we had to do to get what
we had to get and to be able to see
a legitimate Venture do so well
and and those opportunities become
available to me and so many other people
uh
that's what I kind of locked into like
we can go legit you know and and
basically figuring out creative ways uh
they they figured out creative ways to
tell stories
that uh
that could capture the masses
and uh I just thought that was such a
creative even now when I when I'm around
Snoop or
uh and I see him
do things so effortlessly like he just
it's just like
it's nothing to him you know it's like
all these years he could still remember
lyrics that he did
30 years ago I could just compose it
seconds ago
and uh even being around Dr Dre has been
in his home studio and watching him and
his team uh
you know conduct four orchestras
it's like
what happened here you know like and
they still are coming with music and
they're still working with young people
and they're still
open it's like it's no like I hear no
I'm done I hear none of that it's just
like every day and just to be in those
environments and
and just you know being recognized by
those individuals as somebody that had
an integral part in what they did
um
and amen stupors more than most
uh
are prettier connected when it comes to
that
you guys took off right out the gate
with that throw but it almost seemed
like unfortunately you kind of went away
as fast as you came I mean your work
stayed forever but the entity kind of
went South after only like a handful of
years or you know was uh was back to
management again you know yeah what
would you what would you have done
differently managing and with sugar with
sugar good manager well I just say this
about [__] you know I think I think she
was really creative
and uh
and he was in the right place at the
right time and and he was able to
connect the right people and so in the
beginning it should to me could have
been
one of our
biggest entrepreneurs
had he not uh imploded you know it I
know him you know I mean I used to sit
with him and I used to talk with him so
I know the side of should that most
people don't know
and we've considered ourselves Brothers
at one time you know it was a close bar
and to see him unravel and and to uh
pull away from these opportunities that
was surrounding him
it's just a tragedy you know because I
know what difference should and and so
uh
but uh
yeah it went away for a little while but
it's back
right back and it's strong and uh people
are looking at it different and so I
have nothing negative to say about
anybody because I just think that's
wasted energy I just think we all did
what we did uh and sometimes I can be
wrong about certain things the next
person can be wrong about certain things
it's just how
you know it's how you deal with the
present you know and
and how it can death row be seen
differently with the new generation and
so we're about to see am I at my last I
started my last company when I was about
25 years old and we grew we had dozens
of employees and the average age at one
point was like 23 24 25 and I was the
adult in the room I don't drink I don't
party I don't do any drugs I'm
completely sober but a lot of my people
would and it was a creative business
and whenever they would start drinking
and stuff I would always have to put
someone in charge and I'd be like hey I
got to get out of here I don't want to
be around this
um and like managing young people
particularly in a party environment and
particularly creatives
that's a challenge you have to like give
them
the lanes to stay within and let them be
free within those lanes and from an
outside perspective you dealt with that
times 10. you know they were just
drinking and um you know making bad
decisions at the bar some you know Snoop
got
um he was in trouble for um there was
some some some worse stuff that was
happening and all those guys had issues
what's that like managing creative wild
guys well you know it's called putting
out the fires but you know you spoke
about Snoop he was designerated he's got
that case too so yeah and I'm not saying
he did anything I'm just saying that's
hard managing I imagine it was
challenging managing creative people who
also had a wild side or sometimes would
be uh in a circle of of getting in
trouble regardless if they did it or not
what what in that in that particular in
music or any creative I just think that
you have to take people where they are
you know and so what happens is
if you take away if you take away
something
it takes away something
and so we all get to elevate in life and
so who you were and what you came from
and the condition that the way you were
conditioned to see the world
all of that had something to do with the
way the music was made
and so I'm not justifying behavior of
any kind I'm just saying that you start
where you start and if you look at what
you're talking about about some of the
conduct that different individuals uh
participated in early on and you look at
them now
you know these guys are philapathists
they they they have Charities they have
foundations they have they they they
change they help and motivated Mentor
other people in their careers so yeah
yeah that throw was all of that and
that's what made it exciting and that
was the energy that it possessed and but
it grew and some people
blur and some people didn't and some
people went up and some people went down
and it's just it's you know you're
talking about a Shakespeare and play I
mean you there is no other you know it's
just you know a lot of people lost their
lives and careers and a lot of people
became quite wealthy as well so it's
just a combination of it all you know so
the story is still being told
do you think that that creating death
row is is that there the thing you're
most proud of career-wise well my career
is not over sir and so so far yeah so
far I just think that it's the most
impactful uh good bad like I said good
bad it's yeah I can go somewhere and you
know people from all over the world
recognize the brand and uh and and I and
you'll be surprised people from high up
in different uh parts of this Society
classes Society has told me that when
they were in college or whatever they
were doing that that music dude I listen
to it all I know every word to
California love to hit them up I mean I
know all these words I I grew up in
Missouri as a you know as a 12 year old
white kid in Missouri I don't relate I
mean I don't experience what they
experienced but like there was a
rebellious side of me where I go I want
to stick it to the man I wanna and I I
like what I loved about Pac in
particular here's one of my hero I love
that he accomplished so much what how
old was I think he died in September of
what 96. yeah um he he was he was 25 he
was a young guy and he had
she had an Artful side to him you know
these old interviews when he's 18 19
when he's talking about uh I think Jada
Smith or um and talking about like you
see the love that he has for this woman
he's being Artful and he's talking about
um like Brenda had a baby these songs
are like real issues but then he also
got he got charged with rape and he also
was you know the whole Hit Em Up thing
and with with all these other guys he
was fighting and what I love about him
is that he was a flawed character who
was mostly good and he redeemed himself
like he would screw up and then he was a
he was a rich character and I was drawn
to that I'm like I got flaws you know I
had substance abuse issues and I
overcame him and I did all this stuff
and I was drawn by people who screwed up
and overcame and then maybe screwed up
again and overcame and had this
rebellious bold part of it and that's
why I was drawn to it even though I
can't relate anything to selling drugs
or to work any of that well even some of
those charges like yo with Tupac we're
not here to defend a revisit the case
but we know that a lot of times you you
have to guard the people that surround
you as as much as you guard the food
that you digest and sometimes you could
be a big big name person and other
people around you could do something
that you get it because you're the
you're the easy victim you know you're
the one with the big paycheck or you're
the one with the big name and sometimes
you you suffer the consequences of the
people that you allow in your circle so
it's important to always be conscious of
that because uh a lot of times I mean he
was rebellious he fought back he fought
against he was raised he was conditioned
to do so but at the same time A lot of
times things were put on him that really
didn't have nothing to do with it but at
a young age at a real young age when you
have the spotlight I mean he was famous
since he was really young and I admire
that it was famous it was very talented
and like you said we all flawed and and
so it's just we're human beings and then
when you go back and you look at the age
if you look at somebody is 25 years
agent now and you'll be like wow this
kid accomplished this much and he was
able to have this type of mindset and
was able to be able to translate that
into the music I mean come on I mean
this is just and everybody that worked
with him always tell me about he was a
consummate's uh a professional you know
hey you know we got a push we got to
make this happen and uh you know he you
know it was something else and he was
prolific he had all those albums at such
a young age he was prolific so I I
identified with those characters even
though on paper there wasn't a lot that
I could relate to but I identify with
their
maybe not identified but I admired them
I was like dudes guys at Young ages
changing cultures and I think it was
that's interesting it's funny he's
saying that because
uh
my thing is
I think it's I think it's infectious I
think the sound the energy was
infectious so you didn't have to
actually come from that particular
culture to to Really identify it just it
it met you where you was it provides you
with some energy that helped you do
whatever you were trying to do it was I
think it's more about the energy that it
possessed you know like uh people you
know who garyvee is Gary vaynerchuk
right he's you know people I watch him
sometimes they get amped when I'm having
a bad day and then but when I was
younger it was I would listen to hit him
up or something it's like you know what
I'm saying like it it gave me it gave me
fuel to to get back on track and so I
thought it I mean I I just love that
stuff I also that's why I like startups
I like people who are just nerds playing
on the computer and they they create
Bitcoin or you know what I'm saying like
they create something that sticks It To
The Man and even though they're just
you know in Silicon Valley in an office
whereas you guys were down there and and
um uh writing music it's like it's still
kind of a rebellious energy of US versus
the world that I I think is infectious I
I think there's quite relatable uh the
uh a lot of the internet Tech uh
entrepreneurs but that that whole you
know creating something out of nothing
uh I think it's relatable for uh people
in the hip-hop business you know
creating something that was was meant
for a particular Circle that went
outside the circle and and affected the
world and so same way with these young
enterprising uh uh Engineers who uh
create something that we all use like
the phones and the different apps and
and now that whole world is merging and
trying to find this place so it's quite
interesting and to see how it all falls
out you know a lot of big companies have
been displaced because of the internet
and don't know how to find a place and
it allows for new merging uh creative
minds to take its place so I'm excited
about what the future holds
I have a lot of takeaways from talking
to you it's just like
I think that a lot of entrepreneurs like
myself
I'm real emotional you know like you're
into the Arts and building businesses is
my art and people who are sometimes
artistic
I go up and down I get real sad
sometimes I get real happy you know I'm
not calm like you are all the time I'm
trying to work on my calmness just to be
a little more steady you know you were
you experienced a lot harder stuff than
I have and you have remained you have
this cool attitude I said it's like
Clint Eastwood and so uh I think you
kind of inspired me to be calmer well I
think with me in particular you know I
was in a situation where it was quite
volatile
and I had a conversation with god and
and
um I felt that I reached an
understanding and and at one point I
said if I never go home from here and I
never live another day just the fact
that I know who the Creator was and I
was thankful for what God has done for
us as to and what we had to do to even
be bored and so the miracle of our birth
and how important that is to to live up
to that and so you can't help but to be
calm once you know that
each person is is considered a miracle
it's just for you to live up to it and
that's another thing you got a good
attitude you got a really good attitude
it makes me I I get calm being around
you and I feel more optimistic uh and I
also uh you know I've always been
fascinated by these people who
are a little mysterious there's a little
more there's always a little more behind
that you don't even know and they're
always got something up their sleeve
some good story or some cool experience
that they've had and uh I get that vibe
from you and it inspires me a little bit
I think it's cool I also think um you
know last night the Grammys were on and
uh I think it was they had the they did
like the 50 years of hip-hop and the
Ghetto boys were on singing one of their
songs and um they got the uh they had
this one line where they go uh real
gangsters don't flex nuts because they
know they got them and uh that's uh
that's kind of how I feel about you is
uh when you're when you're you know when
you're like the guy you don't gotta say
you're the guy yeah yeah you yeah you
are who you are and then and trust me uh
when you're in situations like I've been
in you know it's it's you know you're
gonna raise you're gonna rise to the top
or you're gonna fall to the bottom you
know it's just you know and it was weird
being there and being away and like I
said especially early on was very
dangerous but I come from a certain type
of community and I conducted myself a
certain kind of way and I was able to
get through it without a scar and then
later on to be able to be there when
Chris and other people like Chris and
his wife Beverly was able to create
programs where people could really
engage and and recognize real change in
themselves uh so I haven't seen it go
from you know where you can't even you
don't know if you're going to live the
next day to a man it's gotta get
prepared for the outside world so you
know so and I'm glad uh Chris introduced
us uh last mile is a very uh Progressive
uh program let's teach people how to
code while it is
so prepare them for job opportunities
when they get out in the uh Tech world
so
man I appreciate you doing this this is
awesome where uh you have an Instagram
is that where people is that where you
connect with people most
well yeah the uh was the official Hario
uh did you see it the official Hario I
think that's what it was it looked like
it was you posted yeah yeah Michael
herrio Harris the official herio on
Instagram I mean you have 41 000
followers there it looks like a picture
of you on a private jet or some type of
Sprinter van I don't know what you're
doing smoking a vape
it's a vapor rabbit but yeah you know
what that's the that's the uh official
uh
uh Instagram but I'll let you I'll let
you know when I set up the podcast I can
talk to you all day yeah
I like getting to know you better
because I want to ask you all these
stories but I want to be respectful you
know uh because I look up to you so much
but there's so many stories that you
have that you know you could talk for
hours and hours and hours I'm sure well
as long as it's an exchange like I said
I'm gonna be set up to be able to invite
you on my show and I want to ask you
about some of the enterprising things
that you've done that would be an open
book for you to be able to ask me
different questions that come up and and
different things that we're going to be
involved in a lot of things that we
we're going to launch this year I can't
speak about it as yet in film projects
as well but next time we talk some of it
will be uh came to fruition and we'll be
able to talk about it hey and I got
stories too just every story you have
divided by 10 and that might be as
exciting as my stories but you're not
gonna feed me that
actually I'm getting into the podcast
world because of what you do and and
people like yourself and the way you
bring uh insight to to the business
world so I'm looking forward to being in
that lane with you all right all right I
appreciate it man you're awesome thank
you I really look up to you thanks for
doing that appreciate you thank you for
the opportunity
[Music]
foreign